all right guys
bang bang i've got reid here super
excited to talk about
memes and making money on the internet
thank you so much for doing this
yeah thanks for having me on for sure uh
let's jump right into your background
kind of
help everyone understand just who the
hell is reid what'd you do before uh
before you got into
the media game um i did not come to the
meme
world or the the media world i guess the
meme world was like
always around but not really popular
with people and
um i was still taking classes in college
when i got into
uh instagram basically and the meme
uh illuminati um i started an account
called [ __ ] steve and
started it as a way to like troll my
friends in the beginning
and then it turned into like oh wait i'm
gaining followers and then i started
reposting stuff
um this is around the time that like uh
[ __ ] jerry and fat jewish had like 100
000 followers and
i just saw them as like whoa that's
that's insane
and uh and i started making original
content that's kind of what
locked me in and helped grow the
my business got it and so when you
started doing that i'm assuming you had
no
you know idea you're going to start a
media company you had no idea that you
were going to kind of
do any of this it was literally just
like screwing around with your friends
but at what point did you end up
deciding like oh wait a second like this
could be a business and i should
actually like go do this
rather than just you know be the uh the
person behind [ __ ] steve on the
internet
yeah so like i started the account
thinking it was a business idea
like my friends thought i was so dumb
and so did my parents they're like
get out of our basement um but uh i saw
it as like a
way to sell ads in the beginning because
i saw um
i was kind of following gary vaynerchuk
just he was an interesting guy
and uh he got me into like the social
media thing
um so it was like it was kind of like a
leap of faith with the advertisement
stuff and then
i started selling like shirts and i
realized that it was more than just
advertisements but that's basically like
why i started it
got it and when you didn't jump you know
kind of into okay i want to build this
business did you
think early on about protecting the ip
um and kind of really
think it is more like a franchise or was
it literally just get eyeballs onto an
account sell
ads and kind of we'll figure it out from
there yeah so there's some other people
in the meme space that had a few
different pages
um after i had been running [ __ ]
for about a year and i only had one page
and i was like wait i could just
replicate this um and then that was when
it was kind of like oh i'm creating all
these new brands
like pretty or like very organically
completely
naturally and i was just like you know i
mean trash getting paul which is like a
weirder version of [ __ ] at sea
and there's all these niche uh areas
where i could like create an account and
then there's like a type of content
that i could source or create for that
brand so
that we did that with like animals doing
things and
gamers doing things and then derek my
co-founder
um he had a video page called drunk
people doing things and it was starting
to really take off
and uh and now advisor and partner to
the business max
um one of my good friends he was like
you need to get into video and so
i partnered up with derek i mean we
started like a
media uh conglomerate kind of thing for
memes uh
in the originally i mean now it's like
expanded bigger than memes you know we
have original show
called august no breaks but it all
started with memes and we all
all of our stuff starts on instagram
got it and so uh where does the name
should head steve come from
trash can paul like these are great
names and i think there's an entire
generation of people who are like yeah
duh like that's the
kind of follow on the internet but
somebody came up with it's like where'd
that come from
uh just like i was like hung over one
day on my friend's couch and we were
coming up with like
stupid names to call each other and
[ __ ] steve and trashy and paul i i
like came up with those randomly
and then i was like okay what should the
profile picture be when i
was like wait i should start an account
and call it [ __ ] at steve
and the username was available which i
thought was crazy
um and i just like made it squints from
the sandlot because that was like a
a movie i loved and it was just like an
iconic nostalgic
character from our generation so that
was
kind of like it was like a random name
and then also
somewhat of a random picture
you know there's like solo cup
idea and i was like i'll just do
something iconic you know
that's like more me and that was it and
i kind of looked like him i guess a
little bit
so i loved that uh so talk a little bit
about you go from
creating one meme page to kind of two
three and grow from there
uh i'm assuming it gets easier because
you've got the one account to kind of
leverage but how did you think about
really moving the audience you
originally built on the [ __ ] steve
account
between all the other accounts to kind
of grow them all together yeah so
when i just had [ __ ] steve and i was
like you know i had like 20 000
followers
we were all talking with like i was
talking to derek
we weren't teamed up yet um there's all
these other memers out there and we
started a group chat
and basically i made a spreadsheet of
like each account and
each day was a different person's day
and we would like
all collectively shout out that account
so like you know there's female
skewed audience pages on there there's
all these different types of
uh pages where there's some audience
overlap but not much and we just kind of
like
do a shout rotation it really blew us up
and then so we took that same concept
from you know when i just had one
account and we were just growing each
other
for fun you know just sharing the love
of the audiences
liking memes and so we did that with the
different brands that we
owned down the road got it
and it's really interesting to me how
the meme culture
just an entire generation gravitated
towards it like
why is that right like what is it so
special about the memes is it that
they're shareable that they're funny
like
you are an expert in memes i guess so
just like
why does this work i think it's a mix of
like
memes are a form of like just super
shareable
ideas and it's just like people can uh
they really resonate with a lot of
people
at once and it's like something everyone
can kind of like come together on and
like
you see the likes going up you see your
friends commenting or
you know tagging their friends or liking
it or whatever or your friend shares it
in a group chat it's just like
something that uh it's either like
nostalgic
which makes it shareable or it's like
really
hilarious and that makes it terrible or
relatable which is usually funny as well
but
i think it's just the easiest and
quickest way to share
funny stuff with a friend it's like the
cartoons that are in the paper except
it's
on your phone and you can easily send it
and that goes with more than just memes
you know it's like
all the tick tock content you see all
the you know
with our show august no breaks it's
pretty memoified in terms of the editing
of the video
and like how it's like quick and it
caters to the
the zero attention span followers like
myself included i have no attention span
so i like
stuff that i'm looking at on my phone to
be really funny like quick
so i don't have to keep staring at my
phone i guess um
i don't know if that answers the
question but that's kind of like how i
see him
yeah that makes a ton of sense and talk
a little bit just about once you had a
couple of accounts they were growing and
they were kind of very meme centric how
did you end up building a whole business
behind this right
like what were the steps you actually
took to build uh the media company
yeah um started with just
like looking at each of the accounts
content
and like what common themes are always
coming up
that gives you a lot of clues uh from an
e-commerce
uh standpoint like okay
you know epstein didn't kill himself is
trending so maybe we could make an ugly
christmas sweater
and just put that phrase on there and
make it look funny
or look good but it's also funny and so
we did that you know around christmas
holidays
um and like that's really really
the main thing for e-commerce for us is
looking at the
the content trends and like the
engagement
you know within the first three minutes
of posting something
we'll know if it's the new thing like if
it's the new meme
like we'll know within three minutes as
you know on twitter you know you'll see
your engagement start to spike
on you know quicker than normal tweets
or whatever i don't know twitter
we have like zero followers on twitter
but uh but instagram is like
you know similar i feel like in the way
that you are kind of tracking that
um but yeah that's how we we realized
for e-commerce that was like
an easy way for us to make money there
advertisements you know for each brand
has its own
perfect uh brand partner you know like
middle class fans is one of our accounts
uh lee the creator of it um he
uh was talking about crispy boys like
five years ago and like created this
term
and bud light wanted to be attached to
it and so that was like a way to
take ip that we've created and uh like
marry it with bud light and now bud
light is a crispy boy
um and that was part of the the campaign
we did with them
so yeah it's kind of like we've we've
been just growing as quickly as possible
and you know with in terms of followers
and revenue we're kind of like in the
beginning we're just grabbing cash
wherever we could and figuring out
what was the most promising thing and i
and advertisements
merchandise and uh you know now like
subscription with patreon
for uh augusto breaks each brand has its
own path to success
so whether it's gamers doing things with
twitch you know we have a
a talent his name spencer he's the host
of the stream we're doing tournaments
that's the path to success for gamers
and also merge
and advertisements uh but like august no
breaks it's patreon
uh advertisements soon on the podcast
merchandise are big for that brand so
merchandise and advertisements are
pretty consistent across the board but
there's different ways you know for each
one to
be built out into its own business like
[ __ ] seat is going to be
and already is kind of like the spencers
of
2020 online you know gag gifts where
it's a puzzle that looks like
uh you know a field of puppies and
you know hanging out and then you open
it it's like a bunch of big dogs taking
huge shits
in a field it's like a prank puzzle that
we did around coronavirus
so that's just like an example of like a
few different brands of ours that like
take take their own lives and like
grow in their own ways talk a little bit
about all gas no breaks for those that
don't know what like what is that
um so august new breaks is a
uh show uh we partnered up with andrew
callahan who is the host and uh
he had a former thing he was doing in
new orleans where he would interview
drunk people
and it was like amazing and a lot of his
content was getting uh
shut down because it was so insane and
so he came to us
and was like we'd love to do a show with
you guys i'm a big fan of the meme pages
and we're like yeah this is
amazing like this we've been following
your content for a while
um and so we took our audience
and basically supercharged the growth to
the show
we partnered up we bought him an rv we
sent him around the country
uh interviewing you know tons of
different people like
flat earthers or uh you know conspiracy
theorists people
um talladega just like really funny
like iconic american things but also
like underground
american subcultures that you've never
heard of that are ridiculous or
really interesting um and so yeah it was
just like us helping him out
uh from a creative standpoint and also
growing the show
and starting the patreon and the merch
business and
um i think we're number six on patreon
now on the whole platform
so that's really cool like in a year uh
we did that
um but that's basically what it is like
andrew's this like
he has this deadpan look on his face and
like he just lets people talk
on into a microphone and it's hilarious
so
definitely check it out and i think a
lot of people understand advertising
they understand the merchandise business
you mentioned patreon let's start there
what exactly is patreon and why is that
working for you guys i think you guys
have over 16 000
uh people who have kind of supported you
there yeah so
it is exclusive
and long form content um the instagram
is short clips you know a minute long
each basically um that helps promote the
youtube we also are on youtube
so basically take the longest and most
raw footage
put it into the longest form we can on
patreon
and uh you know any behind this behind
the scenes content we'll do
on patreon only um
and then we'll take shorter clips of
that um
you know like a 10 minute version of it
or sometimes like seven minutes
at the shortest on youtube and then we
uh
take the really short stuff and put it
on like instagram and tick tock and
uh yeah that's that's basically it um we
have a facebook page but um it's mostly
instagram youtube and patreon and like
those three help
grow each other everything you guys do
is stuff that you own the ip or this is
stuff where people will come to you you
actually can kind of put
um you know kind of gas on their fire
and help somebody else grow
yeah so we created the show we hired him
as the host and he's a partner in the
show
with two of his best friends um so
that's that's how we did all gas and
that's how we operate
um for any other shows we have a few
other shows in
uh in the works and that's gonna be the
same got it and talk a little bit about
the importance of intellectual property
so i think a lot of kind of creators
they understand hey if i get a big
audience i can sell ads maybe i can sell
some merch
um but that's pretty much where it ends
right that's kind of the monetization
strategy
you guys are thinking of this much more
almost like hollywood franchises right
where you kind of take that
intellectual property and really
leverage it um for all of these
different monetization channels
where did that come from and kind of
talk through how you guys have done that
successfully
yeah so we we kind of see ourselves as
like
a weird version of like nickelodeon or
or maybe it's like in tv like we want to
have
we want to create these shows and
channels
that um you know each have their own
universe kind of like i guess kind of
like a marvel
also um you know there's different
characters in the
august show and andrew is one of them
the rv is like a common theme and
there's all these like
things we can play with and and build
out businesses
on their own you know like uh we have
you know for [ __ ]
we have a board game that's gonna be its
own
entity but it's you know born on
[ __ ] steve and we promote it through
[ __ ] steven
so like some of our accounts are really
just marketing vehicles
some of our accounts are actually their
own brands that
have their own ip like [ __ ] at steve
you know it's a lot of viral products
and stuff like that but like august no
breaks is
creating a lot more ip in its its own
right
um but yeah we just want to get as big
as possible and
just be an ip factory kind of like a
disney slash marvel such whatever
and just keep uh there's it's just like
limitless in terms of how big it can get
um
now that we're branching outside of just
memes
um i think having a good understanding
of
memes and comedy and like internet
comedy specifically it's just
helps so much with even like production
of
uh you know longer form stuff that's not
just
images um so we want to just keep
expanding in that way
yeah and it feels like you guys
understand uh creating content you
understand internet culture right so
we talked about the memes uh talk about
the jorts maybe i think people find that
story hilarious
yeah so uh we
were just like hanging out in the office
back when people had offices like
a year ago and uh we were like
talking about jorts or something or
maybe uh cargo shorts
just like really memeable things and uh
we're like we should make
a jorts bathing suit um where it looks
like jorts and uh it's not
and uh so literally like
a few days later we had them made and
there
it was like sublimated bathing suit
basically that really looked like george
and uh a guy that works for us you're
like hey you want to go to my pool
across the street and take a picture and
we literally just like walked across the
street
took a picture of our iphone that was
the shoot
cost zero dollars and then you know we
sold like
a ton of those um it's really funny
and so when you guys have a situation
like that right i think a lot of people
like oh i've had this crazy idea but i
don't actually
execute how do you go from oh it'd be
funny to make a swimsuit that looks like
george to
four or five days later you actually
have the jorts and it's like let's take
the photo and let's launch it like where
does that propensity for action come
from
and like what would maybe your advice be
to other people who have the ideas but
they
get blocked from actually going out and
executing it yeah definitely just take
the path of least resistance especially
with
uh new ideas um like with us
the reason we're valuable is because we
have an audience of 60 million followers
we can
test products for free basically like
so and on top of that we pretty much
lined up the different partners that
could do the [ __ ] that we're not good at
like we're a media company we're good at
being funny
making the content around products and
stuff so we you know outsourced
a sublimation partner who could just do
it really quick and send us a sample
you know at no cost to us and then we
basically
did a pre-sale um and every time
someone bought one you know we would
just place an order so we we just did it
that way it's kind of like an on-demand
model but more
like a pre-sale and fulfill all orders
right when and then cut it off
you know um so that's kind of how we did
that but uh but yeah just like
before that i i made this uh easy button
that was a trump button that was it's
like a wall button
is what it was called it was a meme uh
where you know anything that pissed
trump off he would just hit the wall
button and like all his problems would
go away because the you know build the
wall thing was like a meme
and so what i did was i like went on
alibaba and
placed an order for like a few thousand
of these easy buttons that
we i turned into the meme and sold out
of them
um and i mean it was like such a pain
having to go through that whole process
alone when it was just me running [ __ ]
at steve so
um now that we're we have partners that
can do that stuff i will absolutely
you know let them handle it and take a
slightly smaller margin
um so i guess that is what i would
suggest like definitely
use all the resources you can use the
internet and up work
like to build you can do anything now
wherever you are as long as you have
wi-fi
um pretty much so absolutely how did you
go about finding
employees and kind of building out the
team right there's so many people who
think they're funny on the internet but
they're not there's so many people who
are creating content that sucks
like how do you actually find the right
people who can either run an account
can kind of help with the ecommerce
products and it's not just you you know
kind of micromanaging but actually
finding people
who can kind of make your life easier
but still be effective and grow the
business
for sure so creatively those people
already were like
pretty much our good friends on the
internet after years of growing in the
meme space
we looked at who was growing you know
just as fast or faster or whatever
and we liked their content we were just
like hey do you want to
come work with us and uh you know we
acquired
middle class fancy doggos doing things a
few others and brought the creators on
full time to help us build this you know
they have a piece of
uh doing things and know it was a cool
uh and smart
like really glad we did this because
they
they just get it you know they already
they don't need any training or anything
they're just
doing what they're already good at and
we just help amplify their brands
um and then uh
what was the other question i'm blanking
in in terms of
uh like the non-content employees how do
you kind of find the right people there
yeah so um max uh
advisor and partner to the business he's
helped out early on
helping put the pieces together for you
know like
our basically like our financial arm
we have like a company that uh is a
small partner of the business also that
uh does all of our finances like
anything at the company
and they're awesome uh they manage a lot
of like really uh like hollywood
illuminati people's
money and they're like really helpful um
in terms of like
sales um i brought on todd anderman from
group nine he's been amazing i just hit
him up on linkedin like i saw that he
worked at another media company um
called group nine and i was like
i looked into it he seemed awesome and
and we ended up just you know hiring him
as a president
uh a year ago um so i used a lot of like
social media linkedin
and um networking
uh for sure and uh todd's been really
helpful finding more people for the
sales team and stuff like that and also
just
across the board helping us out with
hiring
um you know some project managers came
from other companies that i worked
i worked directly with them when i was
like running [ __ ] steve
there's a company called herb which is
like a weed themed page on facebook that
like i would share their content and get
paid for it
basically and my in the point person
there we
we brought her on uh and she's been
awesome her name's amanda
but uh yeah it's a lot of networking
online
searches linkedin and social media
i guess do you guys have aspirations to
get outside of just e-commerce from like
uh selling things to people right so you
talked about your advertising
e-commerce makes sense you've got
patreon will you eventually get into
whether it's building
hardware products or building software
products actually try to kind of
get into you know the higher margin more
scalable type things that seem to be
attractive to some creators yeah we're
thinking about doing a uh
we're thinking about creating a
technology that's
kind of like taking everything we know
and our brain
meme brains and like the internet trends
uh side of things and turning it into a
data
type uh oriented technology um
that brands can use and uh you know
basically just help uh companies or
brands or whoever understand what's
you know what is trending or like
you know we do a lot of advertising
campaigns with memes and integrating and
like organically rather than like paying
paying a platform
um so that's definitely one thing we're
thinking of
in terms of uh hardware i can't really
think of anything there we're definitely
wanting to do like live events and we're
just trying to build businesses off the
platform overall
like and we see commerce as part of that
like building brands
whether it's a beverage or a
card game you want to build things that
like would outlive the platforms and
grow on their own got it and
in terms of um kind of scaling this out
it feels like you guys have done a
really good job
uh using that initial traction with
[ __ ] steve on instagram build
other instagram accounts and then kind
of build the business from there if you
did not have any of this right like
there was no accounts and you were
starting today
what platform would you look at and why
that platform
i think instagram's still great um it
depends on what you're making like if
you're creating
video content and it's you know you can
do a 10 minute episode i would say
youtube
but i think instagram is a great place
to get discovered with
reels there's ig tv and there's you know
the the regular
posts in the feed um but yeah i don't
know
it depends on what you're doing like
you're an influencer
it might be something like reels and tic
toc at the same time um
instagram's still great though i think
probably instagram
talk to me about monetization in terms
of how do you guys think about selling
the advertising is it per cpm
is it per post is it maybe monthly like
how do you think about that
and for those people who aspire to be uh
creators whether it's under their own
name or
under um kind of these uh these account
brands
how should they think about early days
monetization versus late stage
monetization once they're big yeah um
kind of a tough question uh can you
repeat the last part so uh talk just
about
how you guys monetize that do you charge
by cpms or some other model
and then in terms of did that change
over time right when you were starting
out did you guys monetize you know one
way and then over time it kind of
evolved something else
yeah i mean in the beginning it was
literally like what's your budget and
they'd say
you know like 10 grand we're like okay
well we need
you know 20 grand or whatever like it
was super scrappy in the beginning it
was just like
us hustling ads like we used to do ads
for
just like the most hilarious you've
never heard of them like drop shipping
companies and stuff in the very
beginning
um but now and you know in the past the
past three years
it's been cpm based um so it's
it's it's understood by
agencies and brands like across the
board because it's kind of how they
operate anyways
so impressions uh you know with a cpm
got it and in terms of um building out
these kind of ip
or brand type accounts do you guys kind
of have
triggers in your mind so hey when we get
started we know we're gonna have zero
followers
we can get to 50 000 followers with a
couple of mentions on our other accounts
that's when we'll start doing ads
then once we get to 100 or 250 000 then
that's when we'll go ahead and do
e-commerce like
is there some kind of framework you use
or is it literally case by case each
time
yeah it's case by case and it's very
like we'll see what happens you know
like we want to put stuff out and see if
it gets traction we're not going to try
to force a brand
that no one cares about like we'll start
it we'll run it for
a few months and then if it just doesn't
pick up steam and people aren't
converting then it's like
whatever um on to the next so
and we also don't like we have a lot of
accounts that are like you know a few
hundred thousand followers and we just
want to keep growing them
to the million follower mark or more
before we start doing ads
um definitely case by case though like
all gas number breaks is different
we only want to put ads in there that
are really you know across the board is
like this but
for all gas it's a little harder to
integrate ads uh
in in the right way so we're thinking
podcast and also just it's sponsoring a
whole series of episodes
um by a really funny brand uh whether
it's like monster energy or
for a florida man episode or whatever it
is
got it and then talk to me about your
day-to-day kind of what you focus on
right are you still
creative and posting on [ __ ] steve
and a bunch of accounts and
and kind of you know deep in the meme
culture or are you doing other things to
kind of build the business
uh on a day-to-day basis yeah so we're
all wearing like a million hats
um i still will occasionally like
find something or like think of
something and make a meme and just post
it because i'm locked into like my
my accounts that i would post to um
but yeah so i'm the ceo i'm doing a lot
of stuff on the
commerce side that's what i'm focusing
on but i'm also like
helping out on ad stuff when i can and
um
across the board like i'm not doing
everything anymore which is great but
i'm still like doing a lot of stuff and
it's mainly ecommerce
creative um a lot of stuff on august no
breaks just like with
you know picking different events
podcast guests we're actually
launching something really big i can't
talk about but uh
working on that and uh yeah so
a lot of stuff i love it what's the one
thing you wish that you knew when you
got started
um
i wish well part of me wishes that i
didn't go so wide with so many accounts
uh just honestly because it's like okay
now like
they're all amazing accounts so it's not
a bad problem it's like
we just have to hire the correct people
for each one to build it out into
its path to success or whatever but i
wish i would have
doubled down on the ones that were
working more so than i did but i
i mean i did so it's not really a regret
um i wish i wish i had
i wish i hired todd earlier
i mean i guess that's it because i had
to do a lot of sales stuff um for a
while and it was just like
really tough you know doing that plus
e-commerce plus actually running the
pages
um i guess i wish i hired faster i wish
i knew that i could hire faster without
worrying about it
because it was so new to me i was like i
wanted to be very careful about how i
grew
and we still are but it was like how
aggressive should i get i guess yeah i
feel like that's a
fairly uh common thing for people right
is like
um because if you mess it up you'll be
saying the exact opposite thing right
which is like
i wish i had hired slower yeah yeah and
i also didn't know the meme space was
like
as big as like i didn't think it would
get as big as it is but now i'm
realizing
i had this realization a while ago it's
like memes are just a different
form of content and a lot of stuff's
mummified that's not just a picture with
text over it
so it's really just the future of
entertainment on
social media which absolutely
how should companies think about using
memes and gifs and kind of all of these
like new multimedia
uh type communication for their
everyday um kind of marketing right so
it's one thing if you're posting on
[ __ ] steve to use memes and things
like that
but there's plenty of people out there
who say hey i run burger king social
media or
you know i run whatever company social
media should i be using memes or should
i just kind of keep it cool and you know
corporate and just stick to that
yeah i think you're you're gonna see
more and more uh
corporate like like big companies like
burger king and i think they are
we're actually potentially doing
something with them down the road
but like burger king mcdonald's all
these like
um qsr companies are starting to adopt
meme stuff and you know wendy's on
twitter i'm sure you've seen is like
completely a meme
um i don't think you have to go that
hard um
you know it's up to whoever is running
the brand like if they think it should
go full meme like slim jim or wendy's
we're running an account called fruit
bowls right now
for um dole and it's hilarious it's like
a slim jim but for fruit bowls
i think there's ways to
not necessarily post a lot of memes or
any memes on your
company's account on instagram or
whatever but you can work with people
like us
to integrate your messaging or whatever
it is that you want to get out there
in a organic and natural way so it shows
up in people's feeds and they're not
pissed off it's like
oh that's actually a funny piece of
content and then that you know oh by the
way it's an ad it's not
in your face like when uh an ad hits
that's paid and you're like
or it's like on tv you just immediately
whip out your phone
so it's a way to get in front of uh
you know millennials without
pissing them off and they're just like
they're not thinking you're cheesy
necessarily they think you're funny or
whatever they're getting across he's
getting across
got it so it's working with people like
us
not necessarily having to post that on
their own page
yeah that makes a ton of sense um any
words of advice for
uh the people who are running accounts
right now who are kind of more creators
but aspire to be in the position you are
that have kind of a full-fledged
business around this
any advice to them um
yeah i mean if you're running like a
meme account just be creative and
original um that's what's going to stand
out
these days for sure
if you're creating you know anything
like if it's a
something like interviews um
just keep in mind that people have very
short attention spans so if you have
some
long intro people don't care about
intros
like i i've always hated intros i think
you know for like certain youtube
channels and stuff it makes sense but
i think you should just get straight to
the point because people don't have a
lot of time
or you know they don't want to stare at
their phone for too long
so just keep that in mind whenever
you're making content
you want to get the thing started
as soon as people see it yeah that's a
great piece of advice
um i asked the same two questions to
everybody and then you'll get to ask me
one to wrap it up
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
zero to one by peter thiel why that one
it's just such a straight shooting book
it's like
he's done it and this is how you do it
and it's like it's really
really informative and uh super smart
like that guy's a genius um
i'd ask the same question to you
i i cheated because i already know know
this question
and uh i answered with the same three
books which is uh kind of breaking the
rules as well but i always say rich dad
poor dad
uh the richest man in babylon and think
and grow rich
and uh i'd be so when did you read
uh zero to one like how old were you a
year ago
okay so i read those three books when i
was like
20 21 years old which like from a
finance
standpoint like that's a good time to
read and kind of build habits and
change the way you think about money etc
when you're building a business right
it's
probably a good book to read it's zero
to one and so um i think a lot about
like
the book itself sure it's high quality
for most suggestions but it's also like
when did the person read it
because the timing is super important
for what that impact was on that
right yeah another question how did you
um
so you said you got started on twitter
what was
the the tweet or the thing that made it
pop was there any like one time where
you're like that's it or
maybe a tweet uh i had already
worked i used to run the growth team for
facebook pages and so
i like knew how the algorithms worked
i'd helped a bunch of people probably a
lot of
you know we probably have a ton of
mutual friends in terms of these meme
accounts or brand accounts
uh and everyone had sorted on either
instagram or maybe there was a couple
people
on twitter they were trying to figure
out facebook right they were trying to
figure out like these other platforms
where
they hadn't started um and so naturally
i would just get introduced to him and
like the conversations would be
hilarious or like the [ __ ] jerry guys
were a great example they were like so
like we have all these memes and like
it's working on instagram like how do we
like make facebook work and here it is
like
okay like you know you guys should be
teaching us things right you use the
platform better than pretty much anyone
um and so i had seen it over and over
and over again just like what worked
what didn't work
and uh in 2017 i realized like i've
never done it for myself
and i was like what you know what the
hell am i doing and at the time it was
very clear that twitter was a much
better place to do
this type of stuff like if you're going
to go for business and finance
and that um it's harder you know to kind
of do it
yeah and it's also harder to like do it
under your own name when it's on an
instagram or
yeah so i think that a lot of it came
down to like
okay i don't know exactly why this is
going to be valuable but i do know
having an audience will be valuable in
the future so like let's get started
um and then you know you kind of tweet
tweet tweet and you just quickly like
start to like let the audience say like
hey we want more of this and less of
like that other stuff
um and there was a time in 2017 like q4
i could literally just tweet the word
bitcoin and the [ __ ] would just go
you know viral here yeah yeah i mean
yeah it's like you know right now you
could literally just
say portnoy right like dave keeps just
tweeting like stocks only go up and just
explodes
and so it's like you know i think your
point about like
you'll know what content works and what
doesn't work right based on the audience
reaction like that's true on every
platform right it's not just an
instagram thing it's kind of anywhere
yeah for sure second question is uh more
fun
aliens believer or non-believer it's 100
real
why do you think that i agree but why do
you think that because
that they just have to exist i've
watched way too many joe rogan podcasts
to not believe in them so
uh they're i'm there with you bob lazar
i'm assuming you saw that one
that's the one that was really like well
okay they are real
and then there was also the government
thing uh the government's
like when coronavirus was the worst or
some crazy [ __ ] was happening this year
it's like all blur at this point but
like they said yeah aliens are real
pretty much
like there's an alien aircraft in the
world
and uh it's definitely from aliens
that's pretty much what they said
and everyone's like yeah but tyrone of
ours like no one cared
so i was the one guy who's like
they're real i
still am shot like i get the fact that
like the videos had already leaked on
reddit and stuff right i get the fact
that like they're like they're ufos
they're not aliens like
like all of it i'm with you though i'm
like wait time out you're telling me
that the us government is publicly
releasing videos being like we don't
know what the hell this is flying around
and you and i can look with our bare
eyes and see something that we don't
understand explain never seen before
like
you know maybe it's something weird but
i'm with you in uh
that should have been a bigger deal than
it probably uh people made it to be
yeah big believer watch there's a an
august episode about
uh aliens alien con it's pretty good
all right i'm gonna have to go look that
one up for sure uh
you could ask me one question to finish
up what do you got for me
um
i guess you're you're probably
comfortable sharing i was just wondering
like what's your what's the biggest part
of your business and
if you don't want to answer it's all
good you can talk about something else
no uh podcasts by far um in terms of uh
i've tested a lot of stuff like sounds
very similar and i didn't really take
the business seriously like actually
sounds very similar to your story
like at first it was kind of like okay
like i'm doing this thing and like oh
wait the audience is like pretty big
uh and it's like oh wait the audience is
like really big now um
and then it was like maybe i should like
try another platform and i should like
try another play and then like you
realize like oh the audience will like
move with me and
okay like maybe there's something here
um
and i've just been shocked in terms of
uh podcast monetization
um some of it's just you know it's
finance so there's
a lot of disposable income kind of the
perfect demographic uh all these fintech
companies have gotten just absolutely
overwhelmed with like venture funding
and
frankly i think some of them like don't
know what to do with at all so it's kind
of you got like all these things that
that work in favor there
uh but also i've been pretty shocked
like uh i've got
um i don't know if you know what a sub
stack is it's like a paid newsletter
type thing
uh and so basically every morning i wake
up i write a
email and it's just like my analysis on
uh whatever i think is interesting in
business
finance bitcoin whatever uh but i send
it five days a week if you are on the
free email list you get it once a week
if you
pay 10 bucks a month or 50 bucks a year
you get it all five days a week
and you know these guys were like hey
you should try this and i was like
who the hell is going to pay right and
next thing you know i've got i think
it's like the number 10 or 11th
largest one on their site and you start
to realize it's like very similar like
the patreon stuff right like people if
it's good content
i think that they are willing to support
the people who create it
and so it's like pretty interesting when
you start to unpack
you know you can create content you can
do ad supported you could do kind of you
know
audience supported you could do
e-commerce like there's so many
monetization channels
but for me it all comes back to the one
area that i think you guys have done a
great job where other people haven't is
just the intellectual property
right i'm shocked that how many people
haven't uh
they have large audiences but they don't
just don't use it yeah i was gonna say
like another
thing early on that we had to do was
build like a video submission portal
to play defense basically and also be
able to license out videos but uh
people submit a ton of videos to us and
we had to get buttoned up pretty hard on
on the meme pages and the video
pages so i feel you absolutely
where where can people find you on the
internet read or find more about doing
things media um go to
my instagram is re-doing things but i
just post [ __ ] about my dog
or like surfing or something um i'm on
linkedin read haley
r-e-i-d h-a-i-l-e-y
um i guess that's probably the best
place for this
linkedin awesome man well listen thank
you so much for doing this
you guys have built a a very interesting
and awesome company so we'll have to do
this again in the future
yeah thanks